Alden Smith now there was an item not
long ago from Jim Trotter of NFL media
that Alden Smith
was trying to get reinstated he hasn't
played in an NFL game since 2015 he had
a stretch early in his career where he
was averaging a sack a game the guy was
unstoppable 7th overall pick in the 2011
draft taken before JJ Watt he was a
force until things started to fall apart
for him off the field he has been as
mentioned out of the game for five years
Jay Glazer of Fox reported last night
that Smith has signed with the Dallas
Cowboys one year dear to million dollar
base with up to two million in
incentives but let's remember this and
this came up not long ago with Josh
Gordon and there are people who believe
rightfully so that because the NFL has
dramatically relaxed the Marijuana
Policy and the substance abuse policy
generally and there will be no further
suspensions for positive tests people
think that guys who are out there who
were suspended indefinitely under the
old rules they get a pass like a like a
library dispensation like you bring your
book in no questions asked everything's
fine no matter how late it is that's not
how it works that's what we need to
remember the Commissioner still has
exclusive discretion to determine who
gets reinstated and when and those rules
didn't change there's no deadline or
when the Commissioner has to make a
decision so guys like Alden Smith and
Josh Gordon and we're Tavis Bryant and
Randy Gregory and David Irving they're
all at the mercy of the commissioner and
none of that has changed and when they
do get reinstated they can get thrown
back out for a violation that otherwise
wouldn't get a guy suspended under the
new system so we need to remember that
he's not reinstated there's no guarantee
he's going to be reinstated I doubt the
Cowboys know anything because the NFL
doesn't tell anybody anything about the
status of a player who could be
reinstated so that continues to be the
biggest hurdle for Alden Smith yeah he's
got a job if he gets back in there's
still no sign he's getting back in Chris
yeah you're right I mean we don't know
and and you know hopefully we'll find
out somewhere here in the next month or
two okay but added to that you know -
what you're saying - he's got to make
the football team right they're just you
know he's not coming off this
streets of for years of not playing
football and Dallas is going here's a
roster spot yeah you said the contract
details one year four million no
guaranteed money he's gonna have to earn
his spot you know and Alden Smith a guy
that was I mean on a Hall of Fame Ark
early in his career I mean he really he
wanted to freak to your defensive
players and all a football you said it
drafted ahead of JJ Watt I think that
says a lot in itself let alone being a
part of some Super Bowl defenses and be
in a special part that way but it was
one you know mess up an issue after
another there with all that Smith first
thing is I hope he got his life
corrected which it sounds like he did
and he sounds like he's on the right
path so that's a positive now what he
can bring as a football player Mike I I
don't know you know what's he been doing
the last four years that's gonna be the
big question has he been training has he
been staying in shape I can tell you for
one from a guy from experience it's hard
to sit out a football for a year or two
all right cuz that's what I basically I
did with my spleen injury and then when
you get back in you don't feel
comfortable at first because it's just
you're not used to that chaos and those
big people around you the speed of the
game and all those things and even for a
great specimen like Alden Smith I would
think there's you know gonna be an
adjustment period so I knew if there was
one team that would take a chance on it
would be the Cowboys right Mike the
Cowboys kind of got that Raiders vibe
about them where they're you know they
want the the most premium Al Davis
athletes there are speed sighs you know
craziness and Alden Smith certainly has
the freaky ability in size to be a
difference maker if he can get anywhere
near where he was you know in his prime
and the Raiders were the team that gave
Alden Smith his initial second chance
after he was cut by the 49ers Alden
Smith took to Instagram last night after
the news broke and he said life will
always present us with tests I've
learned how to take a different
perspective on the adversities of life
instead of looking at life as a victim
I've embraced the journey as God has
planned at making exponential strides
towards becoming a better man and he
had an extended array of off-field
issues and it's not going to be easy for
him to get back again and again the
procedures under the new CBA have not
changed the Commissioner still has that
exclusive power now the fact that the
supe substance abuse policy has been
softened across the board will that make
the Commissioner more likely to let guys
back in I had noticed Chris and we've
discussed this over the past couple of
years that the NFL has been more lenient
with quality players right I think once
the ratings bottomed out in 2017
somebody realized maybe we shouldn't be
so quick to shove talented players out
of the league who can make the games
better who can make the production on TV
more compelling because they do special
things so I sense that they started to
be a little bit easier on guys maybe
that helps Alden Smith get back in yeah
I would think it does I mean yes we are
in a different time and era that you
know when Alden Smith was having issues
back in 2014-2015
all of that the NFL has loosened up its
regulations to a degree and I would hope
that yea the NFL keeps that in mind that
you know things are different it's not
the same rules as Alton Smith was kind
of a falling falling falling by the
wayside there early on so and to that
point too you know that was always my
big argument Mike with the Marijuana
Policy is the amount of guys every year
that were being suspended or not playing
games who were good football players
over what the fact that they went home
and did that in their own private time
and didn't pop pills or do something
like that to numb pain or make them feel
relaxed or whatever it was so I do think
the NFL is on the right arc as far as
that's concerned I'm just I'm intrigued
by the all Dan Smith thing I mean the
Dallas Cowboys you know like we talked
about they're a collector of you know
freaks of nature athletically and you
know if they can get something at all to
the Smith and they can get Randy Gregory
back in the fold and get him going
yeah there's potential there but you
know the Alton Smith one this is a long
extended time off from football man for
years you know Mike oh can you remember
anybody that long out of the game coming
back and then having an
success off the top of your head I mean
the one guy that stands out is Robert
Edwards who had the catastrophic knee
injury at the football game at the 1998
Pro Bowl and he fought and fought and
came back Ricky Williams was out for
extended period of times remember he
went and played in the CFL during one of
his own year suspensions aside and now
we hear one two years maybe I'm sorry
yeah yeah but here's the other thing too
I don't want to forget to mention this
it's not just a marijuana thing with
Alden Smith his latest attention was the
result of a hit and run DUI and
vandalism incident in 2015 so I think
that makes his situation different than
a guy who was suspended indefinitely for
testing positive or definitely not
complying with all the the requirements
of his treatment plan this is a
situation where it crossed into alleged
or actual violations of the law so it's
gonna be even harder for him to get back
in we need to remember that we need to
remember that and it's it's a good story
and it's exciting from the standpoint of
a guy who was on a Hall of Fame mark
like you said getting back in it'll be
fun to see what he can do but let's just
not let's just not assume that he's
gonna be back and it's all gonna be back
to normal and everything's yeah and
you're right those those mistakes were
egregious and they did they deserve
discipline so I'm not trying to compare
that to the marijuana policy I was just
kind of playing off what you said the
suspensions and talented players not
being out there that's all I was trying
to make the point about oh and I wasn't
accusing you of that trust me I would
have been more direct if I was I just
wanted know that both me and you and
everyone remembered that Alden Smith
isn't the typical case that there are
some issues where he got in trouble with
the law and I think that makes it harder
to get back in than it would be if it
was just testing positive over and over
again
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports